my name is Cedric we're gonna start with
just a quick experiment so I'm gonna
play a note on the keyboard and I want
everyone to hum the sound that they hear
okay we ready are we excited about this
all right so more on that later
Who am I my name is I'm a consultant I'm
a founder of a consulting company I'm an
occasional speaker and an occasional
author of books I work at a company
called span tree and I also do a lot of
stuff with music I'm really into
synthesizers and MIDI and all that stuff
I also used to compose music and so I
got a little bit into music theory there
are some people in the audience that are
probably way better at music theory than
I am so please feel free to correct me
after and I'm also a Spotify addict I
really love music and I really love
playlists they're a passion of mine and
I'm also recovering DJ there'll be more
on that later on so this is a talk about
music theory and that was Mozart back
there a slide ago this is has anyone
familiar with this cartoon all right
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna make
use of fair use copyright provisions and
we're gonna watch a little bit of this
is called a math magic land there's a
cartoon put out by Disney in the 50s to
sort of get children interested in math
go to ancient Greece to the time of
Pythagoras the master egghead of them
all proceed Lawrence the father of
mathematics and music you'll find
mathematics in the darndest places watch
first we'll need a straight stretch it
good and type pocket now divide in half
plunk again you see it's the same tone
one octave higher now divide the next
section and the next Pythagoras
discovered the octave had a ratio of 2
to 1 with simple fractions he got this
[Music]
and from this harmony in numbers
developed the musical scale of today
[Music]
okay so this was probably like one of my
favorite cartoons as as a child I loved
it so much this is actually my AOL
screen name in high school it's
Pythagoras spelled backwards I also I
when I put out some music I actually
went under the pseudonym of Pythagoras
so that's a picture of a high school me
and the the album was called pathology
more on that later also remember when I
said I was recovering DJ that was like
two three minutes ago so let's talk
about College so I had a brief career as
a classical music composer I was like
sort of making music with MIDI and it
sounded something like this and I had a
slightly longer career is just like a
general MIDI musician like kind of
playing around with synthesizers is
everyone familiar with me to you by the
way I figured the strange of the crowd
would be it's basically the protocol
that musical like electronic musical
instruments used to communicate with
each other so I was really into that
also Tom and I made music that sounded
like this but then College happened and
no one was really feeling the classical
music and no one was really feeling the
the MIDI I wanted to make friends and so
I got into DJing because parties and I
hopefully didn't look like this person
but I used to do a lot of mashups and
this was one of my more popular mashups
called
Beyonce rockin beats
[Music]
anyway you get the point what the hell
is that
that was a accommodation of Destiny's
Child losing my breath and then it was
playing over chemical brothers block
rockin beats so so how did that work
harmonics remember Pythagoras he had
that whole ratio things so that ratio
informs what music sounds good together
and there's this youtuber or I'm sorry
and in in this case the Destiny's Child
was in a key of D flat major and block
rockin beats was in a flat of B flat
minor now you would think okay those are
different those are different keys but
it turns out that they actually used the
same notes they're what's called a
complementary key so you can actually
layer those two things on top of each
other and it happens that B flat is a
major sixth of D flat which means that
they shared the same notes and and why
does this matter because the brain likes
to do math but not too much of it so
when we're talking about those ratios
before when we're hearing different
notes or different chords the simpler
the ratios are between the notes the
more pleasing it is to the ear and
there's a whole science behind it
there's this youtuber named Adam Neely
his homie with him yeah alright we've
gotten really fit so he he gave a he put
a video online that sort of explained
harmonics and how the ear process is
sound I'm gonna share a little bit of
that because he does a better job of
explaining it than I can in a compressed
amount of time when the sound of the
clips hits your inner ear a structure
called the basilar membrane will vibrate
in sympathy with the total number of
Clips hitting it per second tiny hair
cells and the inner ear will convert
that acoustic information into
electrical impulses that the brain can
then interpret just the same way that a
microphone will pick up sound waves to
be either amplified or recorded what
happens next I think is pretty
incredible and also not that well
understood our ears can do now
really quickly I'm afraid we need your
use let's take these two sine waves one
vibrates at five hundred and twenty
times per second to the other vibrates
at 650 times per second your ear
automatically calculates the ratio
between the two of them as five to four
this is the interval of a major third
because five against four is a simple
ratio with simple integers our ear
accepts it as a pleasing sound our ears
automatically do what our conscious
brains might have to labor over quickly
calculate ratios between two separate
pitches and boy can they do it quickly
thousands of notes per second can be
processed by the brain with the right
sort of math behind it so what does that
have to do with Beyonce well maybe the
answer lies in the harmonic series the
harmonic series also known as the
overtone series is based upon simple
multiples of a fundamental so if your
fundamental is a hundred Hertz the
second harmonic will be 200 Hertz the
third harmonic will be three hundred
Hertz
just take whatever the frequency of a
note is multiply it by a number then you
get that number harmonic so easy even a
musician can do it we hear all of the
different harmonics as different pitches
and intervals in relationship back to
the root our brains process the
differences between harmonics as musical
intervals the ratios between two of them
create a harmonic interval for example
the distance between the fifth harmonic
and the fourth harmonic creates a
five-to-four ratio or the ratio of a
major third that we heard earlier major
thirds are in our system of Western
harmony but other intervals aren't like
the distance between the seventh
harmonic
so remember we were talking about keys
so the the notes that were included in
both of those songs were basically the
same it's just that you had it different
what's called a root note and when
you're making playlists when you're a DJ
on stage like mixing records together
like the compatibility of those notes
has a lot to do with how easily pleasing
it is and I wanted to take that further
and see if we could teach computers a
little bit of these rules and so we'll
get into that later by the way I forgot
to mention this at the top of the talk
it's generally discouraged to use your
phones I'm gonna ask a participant to
use their phone to find a publicly
available Spotify playlist that we're
gonna optimize together by the end of
this talk so feel free to look something
up in I'll search for it and we'll find
it together and run some algorithms on
it so when we were talking about keys D
flat major is the relative minor or I'm
sorry B flat is the relative minor of D
flat major so what that indicates is
that these notes those notes actually
are the same as the notes on the other
scale the the B flat
I swear to God I practice that I really
I did I did last night the night before
demo gods are never kind okay so so
let's let's see this on a keyboard as we
just did while we're over there remember
that experiment we did at the beginning
of the talk remember we we like we we
were humming a note together well let's
let's try that again but this time I'm
going to manipulate the note so this was
the note that we heard so how many notes
do you think you're actually hearing
there one so with the overtone series
what we were listening to is these draw
bars here are actually impacting the
other pitches that are played at the
same time to add richness so I'm gonna
slowly subtract those tones away
[Music]
so we're hearing all those notes
together but because they were
complementary to each other because they
have very simple ratios they didn't
really sound dissonant they didn't sound
displeasing to the ear but this is also
a talk about playlists now that we have
some of the the music theory background
behind us let's talk about how this
could apply to making our Spotify
playlist sound better so what matters
musically to a playlist there's a lot of
things that matter emotionally to a
playlist like sentimentality and that
sort of thing but from my perspective
there's there's three key components
there's tone and that's the stuff that
we were talking about a second ago
there's tiny or timming and and that has
to do with the tempo and the rhythm and
the time signature of a song and then
there's also also Tambor and Tambor is
actually all of the the relative ratios
of all those tones that we heard so the
tambour of an organ is very different
from the tambour of a guitar because the
overtones are fundamentally a different
structure and that can that that can
make an impact on the pleasing pleasing
Ness to the air as well so let's talk
about tone
are there any djs in the room all right
have you seen the account a lot scale
before no okay
so the Camelot scale is this this graph
that's used a lot in what's called
harmonic mixing when you're trying to
play two records at the same time and
not have them sort of stomp on each
others for prior sound so what what this
represents is each key has a a v up or a
v down so five notes on it scale up and
and if you transition from let's say E
major to B major
that's a pleasing sound however if I
went very far on this scale if I went
from an E major to D flat major
or even worse like an E major to a
b-flat minor because those are so far
apart it will actually sound like a
train wreck it will sound very
uncomfortable and so oftentimes when djs
are putting sets together they will try
to figure out how I could how they can
either stay in the same key for a while
or jump to just one over on the Camelot
scale either left or right or down so
basically what they're doing is is
pathfinding they're trying to find a
path from one song to another by making
a small move as possible on this Camelot
scale to get from one from one song from
one Keys to another and it turns out
that a lot of DJ's get paid a lot of
money to do this and I wanted to apply
this to my own sort of like mixtape
making as I started getting into taking
non dance songs and sort of putting them
into playlists form and so this is an
example of a playlist transition that I
created using this technique analyzing
the the songs of four keys and then sort
of sequencing
[Music]
so there's there's a little bit of a
drone in the background but what you're
hearing there is is basically two songs
that are texturally very very different
but because they match up on the key it
works and and so this was an exciting
thing to be able to do back in the day
when when I actually owned the music and
I had the mp3s but nowadays people don't
really own their media anymore a lot of
the media is in the cloud most people
are listening to music on Spotify or
Apple music and and and less likely to
be able to if I shared a playlist they
would be less likely to play it so the
good news though is that playlists are
everywhere there are pervasive now
there's even PhD theses being written
about playlists and and the the sort of
abundance of playlists in the new cloud
media economy but we can't do fancy
tricks like this where we're layering a
bunch of records on top of each other in
Spotify we can't play more than one song
at a time but what can we do well we can
reorder the tracks so based on those
those music theory notes from earlier we
can create a rule-based system that
allows us to figure out the best way to
structure songs together from one to
another so is anyone familiar with
Ryoichi Sakamoto one person all right
cool so really Sakamoto is is a Japanese
composer he worked with David Bowie back
in the 80s and he's a very particular
individual and when he went to a this
restaurant that he frequented in New
York he was he was really annoyed with
the playlist and so he actually secretly
programmed the playlist using his
musical brain for three years and then
the New York Times found out about it
and they wrote this whole piece about it
and it turns out that there's actually a
lot that you can do when you're
when you're applying these rules and so
this is a talk about discrete
optimization discrete optimization per
Wikipedia is about finding a best
solution and C of the solutions and with
the playlist if you have a hundred song
playlist there are millions of
possibilities for how to order those
songs properly so the TLDR on that is
that you have a finite number of
possible solutions
that's the discrete component of it but
you're also searching those options to
find one that closely matches a set of
rules so what are our rules in in
playlist building the song should play
exactly once that sort of table stakes
you shouldn't have repeats some song
transitions to be two songs in the same
key and other songs should be two
adjacent keys on the camelot scale you
don't want to listen to a playlist
that's all one key and so these are all
rules that we're going to use to
optimize our playlists today and song
transitions should also avoid drastic
tempo changes there Tambor changes as
well you want to gradually shift people
from one mood into another generally but
all the songs are in the cloud so this
is to talk about API integration so who
is familiar with Spotify is wait web api
it's actually quite dope isn't it it's
it's pretty pretty awesome so they when
I when I sought to create a playlist
optimizer I was expecting that I'd have
to go download all this media and build
my own analyzers basically doing tonal
analysis on the mp3s themselves but it
turns out Spotify actually purchased a
company a few years back in 2014 called
the echo nest it was a project out of
MIT and they had actually automated a
lot of this analysis and they exposed
all this data about their songs over the
API so what we end up with is every
single song that's in Spotify right now
I can make an API a call and get the key
indicator the mode the tempo and then a
bunch of other properties like they have
a dance ability property and energy
property and
acoustic acoustic mixed property and we
can we can leave all of these into our
plan our planning system so this these
two lines indicate that this is a song
that's in D major the key to indicates
the the root note and then one indicates
a major mode but we also get a lot of
other helpful stuff for optimization as
well so like if we wanted to optimize
and pay attention to the time signature
we could do that if we wanted to make
sure that we weren't jumping around
between tempos we could we could factor
that in as well so we have the data but
how do we actually optimize for the
playlist so there's this really cool and
sort of under appreciated in my opinion
technology called OpticsPlanet it's an
open source library for the JVM and what
it allows you to do is write a series of
business rules so basically like when
this condition happens penalize the
solution and then it applies a bunch of
heuristics to try to find solutions that
break as few rules as possible so the
steps for setting this up first we model
our domain so in this case a track is is
one of our domain objects and the track
will have relationships to artists and
it will have albums and we'll have a
duration and there's an explicit flag so
you can filter things out if you don't
want things that are explicit and then
you also have this notion of a track so
in addition to just what are called the
facts the the the data about the tracks
we also want to find some way to
represent the relationship between the
tracks so this track is playing after
this other track so then we have what's
called a planning entity and an anchor
so we have to specify where the playlist
needs to start that's that's one of the
sort of non-negotiable pieces of the way
that this optimization system works but
then what you're what you're setting up
as the thing that changes is for every
other track in the playlist it's going
to randomly select tracks that could be
played before and then over time it will
actually create a link
of these tracks together and it will
look for the solutions that violate the
fewest rules and we go into the
mechanics of rules in a second as well
so this is what this looks like in
practice so in our case when we're
creating a playlist we start with one
song and we're going to shift the
relationships between we're going to
shift the relationships between each
playlist track basically by just
assigning a pointer and OpticsPlanet ooh
effectively make those sorts of those
those sorts of experiments thousands of
times a second evaluating whether or not
the the playlist improved and the first
playlist track remains as the anchor and
and we're using this planning variable
as sort of our our independent variables
in the experiment
so during Optimas optimization we're
experimenting with alternative planning
variables to each planning entity and
then we have a solution that's basically
the completed playlist so this is the
all of the tracks their relationship to
each other
and we also have what's called a score
and the score is the thing that we're
going to be trying to get as close to
zero as possible every time you're
playing a track that is in a key that's
not complimentary you basically penalize
the planning system by by a point so in
addition to that we also have facts so
if we wanted to write a rule to say
don't play the same artist like two
times in a row you have data on that you
also have John route information that's
available through the Spotify API that's
for some reason attached to artists so
you could say for example I want to
clump all my jazz songs together I want
to spread them out and finally we have a
score which is used to track the quality
of the working solution and so you have
different levels so different
constraints will take different
priorities so for example if I'm playing
the same song twice that's considered a
hard constraint meaning that that this
should just not physically exist and
then a soft constraint is like ideally I
would like for all the keys to sort of
match up but maybe that's not that's not
feasible so that's what that's what
referred to as a soft constraint so
scores have slots and you can assign
basically weight so in this case like
this solution has resolved all the hard
constraints that's at zero and there's
still some outstanding issues with soft
constraints and so there's some negative
weights there so no feasibility issues
but there are some things that are
suboptimal and and so the system is
going to seek to continue to improve
those things so now let's let's write
some rules this is an example of our
rules using the drools language which is
a it's a pattern matching system for the
JVM so you'll notice this looks a lot
like sequel what I've what I what you're
expressing here is basically a pattern
when I have a track and that the track
is pointing to a different track and in
this case we're trying to make sure that
the song is playing only once when that
track when the track is playing
somewhere else then penalized so so
basically you have this score holder add
hard constraint match down at the bottom
what this is doing is it's saying adjust
the score the overall score of the
solution by negative one and then these
things will be summed up to try to to to
basically try to get as close as
possible to a zero score so we look for
a track that has a previous track
defined we check to see if there's
another track in the solution that
points to that same track and then any
time that happens we add a hard
constraint with a penalty of one and so
this can happen several times in a
solution and what ends up happening when
we're writing the syntax it gets
compiled into a data structure that's
called a Reedy tree our été and
effectively what this data structure
allows us to do is as new information
comes in like play with like tracks are
being reassigned it can quickly reason
through the impact that that might have
on the score and only recalculate the
things that need to be recalculated and
so it's an extremely efficient system as
well but what about key roles does
anyone know who this is says this is
Francis Scott Key he's going to be our
key
ambassador for the key discussions
coming up so we might want to figure out
basically if I have two songs that are
playing back-to-back what is the
distance in the key on a camel on scale
and to do that we add what's called a
shadow variable that shadow variable is
going to allow us to execute some code
that calculates the difference based on
the set of known sort of relationships
between those keys and then we have a
listener and the listeners effectively
going to take and this is a lot of code
this this listener is effectively going
to look for those updates and and figure
out how far away they are on the camelot
scale and update that value in real time
so this is the part that lets us know
when something is happening so anytime
something changes in the role in the
roles in the facts this these methods
will be called and then this will
dispatch basically this imperative
method that will calculate the distance
and so we're doing just a little bit of
math there and then finally this is kind
of an interesting component of the
system as well any time you change a
variable you need to inform the rules
engine that you're about to change your
variable so they can figure out what it
might need to react twos and so we're
basically informing it that this this
variable is about to change we change it
and then we say we're done changing it
and then it will be able to evaluate the
impact of just that one discrete change
so now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and this is in Kotlin our key
rule is is very simple all we need to do
is just look for a playlist track and if
it has a key distance is greater than
zero basically take the the the square
of that distance and penalize the score
so things that are further apart are
going to be exponentially penalized in
this system so since most playlists can
st. contain songs and more than one key
the score will never be zero but
trying to get it to as close to zero as
possible and we could also add rules to
basically say that we don't want to play
more than four songs in the same key so
break up the tension every once in a
while by by introducing something new so
how does it do that there's is anyone
familiar with in Queens the N Queens
system so it's it's often used like
you'll see it referenced in prologue and
effectively what you're trying to do is
is if you have a chessboard you're
trying to move all the Queens to a
position where they can no longer attack
each other and so this is this is a an
interesting problem for an optimization
system to solve because the rules are
very simple
well what the optimization system is
doing is it's picking a piece it's
moving it to a random location and then
it's seeing if it made the score better
so in this first position basically all
the Queens can attack each other when I
move this piece to a different position
now this Queen can no longer attack this
Queen this Queen can no longer attack
this Queen but these Queens can still
attack each other and these Queens can
still attack each other so you have some
constraint violations but you've reduced
the amount and overtime you can continue
moving the Queens until you've found an
optimal solution so you're just
searching through a finite solution
space and that one rule is is basically
dictating the quality of the solution so
the sequence of moves also impact the
next viable move as well and so one of
the things that's that's really
interesting about these sorts of systems
is that they will be intelligent about
the likelihood that a random move is
going to yield a better change so it'll
it'll realize that I just moved this
Queen before and it it made the score
worse in the last type five times I've
moved this Queen it's made the score
worse though that Queens probably in an
optimal position and I'm going to move
on to another another part of the
problem space so optic planner uses
random series moves to in a whole bunch
of different strategies for selecting
those moves
and it's always trying to select the
subset of news that will make the score
better so how does this apply to
playlists let's let's watch our solver
in action so this is from the code base
for this playlist optimizer that I've
written and so what's happening is we
start by basically loading in all the
data and very quickly it's it's looking
through a batch of moves and it's trying
to determine whether the score got
better or worse and so you'll see these
scores here they should be going down
but occasionally they'll go up to avoid
local Optimum's
or local local maximum so so what the
hell was that let's dissect a specific
log line so in this particular log line
we are selecting a move of moving this
song behind this other song and when
we've selected that it will basically
impact the score and the optic liner
system will try to will try to resolve
that impact and keep track of when it
had the best scores and try to return to
those if it gets off track so before it
does that it also just tries to place
all the songs anywhere in the playlist
and so what will often happen is it will
select the best songs at the beginning
of the playlist and then eventually
you'll get into a difficult situation at
the end where you don't have a high
selection of available songs and so
after the construction heuristic is
complete where you can't undo a move
then you move on to a local or to a
local search which allows you to
basically undo moves and backtrack just
the same as you would if you were
playing a game of like hot and cold so
if we if we just do the construction
heuristic we'll hit a local optimum
meaning that the the solution will seem
as good as possible but because a lot of
the decisions have been set in stone we
won't be able to to backtrack from that
and so the local search resolves that
and there's a whole bunch of different
strategies that the local search system
will use and after a long while we'll
end up with and optimize so
so for most playlists it's important to
note that we'll never get a perfect
solution there are often competing rules
that will make it impossible to find a
an absolutely perfect playlist but one
of the nice things about this system
also is that it will tell you what
suboptimal so if we have a rule that's
being violated it'll actually tell you
what songs are in violation of that rule
and then you can manually resolve those
if you want to just with your your own
musical insights so let's see it in
action I had a goal of being able to
launch this tool before the talk and I'm
happy to say it got this up about an
hour ago so so this is this is Spotfire
I'll go ahead and log out so you get the
full user experience so if you go to
Spotfire io you can log in to Spotify
immediately it'll show you your own
playlist and you can see I've been
testing this a lot because you'll see
the same playlist over and over again
but did anyone get a chance to pull up a
Spotify playlist for testing the Obama
2019 playlist all right let's see if we
can find it this one summer playlist
alright okay so it's 44 tracks so it's
what's going to happen and I'll get into
the mechanics of the system in a little
bit we're gonna pull the data down from
the Spotify API I spend a lot of time on
this progress bar it's it you don't
think about those details until you know
the night before your talk and then now
now that we've loaded the data in we
have this sitting basically in the
Postgres database now we're going to
serialize it into a zip file in Amazon
s3 and then we're going to load an
optimizer in AWS lambda and we will
actually be able to see some logs
hopefully of what's going on under the
cover so when I click optimize there's
going to be a router bug because I
discover that a few minutes before the
talk
while we're doing that we can take a
look at our logs
there we go all right and you actually
start to see some of the output here as
well so maybe we'll do a split screen
I'll bump up the font a little bit there
this is what happens when you have a lot
of I turn tabs so you'll see here on the
left this is like the the web interface
telling you what's going on so what's
what's happening is it's moving all
these songs around trying to find a
better fit based on these musical rules
and you'll actually see how many how
many rules are left being violated so
there's a rule saying that key distance
should be kept to a minimum if I'm not
in a complimentary key then basically
they'll be in a violation thrown and so
there are 18 instances in the current
working solution for that violation and
you'll see that there's also a negative
42 score meaning that in certain cases
the key distance is more than one and so
we're actually taking the squares of
those to discourage like super super
large jumps and then we're also we have
another rule saying that we should avoid
playing avoid playing an artist that was
recently played and so there are 28
violations of that as well but I've set
that as a lower priority so that will
then not result in as drastic a bit of
an issue we want to make sure that the
keys are compatible first what's nice
about the system is you can continue
adding rules and the performance remains
mostly mostly the same so if we go to
this Spotfire playlist now we're done
solving
I'll skip the explicit song so we should
hear songs that are now in a
complementary
[Music]
that just jumped up and so these
transitions are meant to be more
pleasing to the ear based on those
ratios that we we discussed what's
really exciting about this this this
system is that if you have a different
preference if you actually don't care
about key compatibility but you let's
say you want to optimize for playing
artists with the same last name
back-to-back all you have to do is just
just change your rules and everything
magically works and oh by the way I
forgot to mention at the top of the talk
this whole project is is open source
there's actually three projects on
github right now that were launched in
parallel to this system so there's the
API that uses prism and Postgres and
node and typescript palo server Nexus
and the Spotify node API because I like
a lot of technologies so that's
basically doing all the heavy lifting of
pulling in the data and managing the
flow of data from the from the user
experience to the solver there's the
website which is serving up the user
experience that's using Gatsby and
typescript again react components in a
router the Apollo client so we're
actually doing some dynamic rendering
inside of a statically rendered website
and we're using autho and and jot tokens
to do the the authentication to Spotify
Annette laughs I for a building and
hosting and we're on the back end for
the solver we're actually running this
in AWS lambda so we're dispatching from
the API to a lambda so that each
optimization process gets its own
discrete set of resources sir for that
reusing Kotlin optic planner drools AWS
lambda and this system is live as of
this morning there are some bugs that
I'll be squashing this this afternoon
but feel free to take it check
get out so I wanted to thank strangely
both the audience and the organizers
I've been going to this conference or
almost a decade now and I also wanted to
thank this pantry crew
so especially Justin Mahdi Sebastian and
Eli they've all helped me with with this
project and with this talk with specific
contributions and then the Spotify and
echo nest teams and some great open
source projects as well so feel free to
check it out issue pull requests issue
issues on this system and and feel free
to use Spotfire just pop fireEye oh
thank you
[Applause]